so i begin with thanks to my
collaborators uh david steins and steve
evans who don't see eye to eye with me
on some things and that i'll talk today
and thanks stephen matheson
here at the simons institute who's been
explaining a lot of things to me to my
student email herati and to richard
sussman who is the patron of all this
work that
brings biodemography and
genetics together
so today is a little different talk from
many this is very much work in progress
or even thoughts in progress there is a
paper that will be coming out in pnas
but this is from the speculative part of
the end of the paper in the discussion
i'm talking about the same model that
david talked about yesterday at the end
of the session
and
you might have been lifted with the
impression that the model
doesn't work that there are all kinds of
pathologies well the pathologies are
what are mathematically interesting
but they can be avoided in perfectly
straightforward sensible ways
by allowing for small
deleterious effects at younger ages
whenever alleles have effects mainly
concentrated at older ages so if you
remove the unrealistic feature of a
sharp cutoff of nothing
up to some age and something beyond it
you get rid of that unrealistic feature
then the models perform very well they
generate a
very good-looking
the mortality schedules uh you we want
to tune them to fit schedules both for
humans and for many other species i use
them in classes constantly
they easily predict a wide range of
empirical behavior without pathology
they behave beautifully
99.7 percent of the time
but the
0.003 percent of the time is what's
mathematically interesting that if you
make the assumptions david talked about
that mimic the assumption that used to
be made
then the models break down so we know
we've got something more than we used to
have but what we mostly have is a
flexible way for incorporating age
specificity into the story of mutation
accumulation
and now although the model applies to
deleterious alleles affecting fertility
and
juvenile mortality i'm going to talk
about a special subset of those alleles
and concentrate on adult mortality today
and so
david talked
about the mathematics and i'm going to
assume that whatever mathematics uh you
wanted to hear you uh gained from david
who really invented the model and
with a lot of help from steven a little
help from me proved the main theorems in
the model so you've heard that and if
you still want more there is a
memoir for the mathematics but i'm going
to talk about empirical tie-ins and
although i've said the model is flexible
as david emphasized it depends on having
some specification for the age-specific
effects of deleterious alleles and these
are
small effects which we can't detect and
so there's no empirical
simple empirical way of finding out what
those shapes should be
and so to ground the model in empirical
reality we have to look toward macro
prediction start a broader brush
a piece to see
what has to be true for the model to be
compatible with what we can see
especially from genome sequences so
that's the problem i'm talking about
today
i am says we have a model that works
works well for demographers is now in
broad use
at least for people who come from
berkeley
and uh
now we're trying to tie this theoretical
work
to
observation and so i want to talk about
and that's not easy i want to talk about
the challenges and so really i'm looking
at four questions to which i will
propose tentative answers uh which you
are
free or encouraged to shoot down or
revise
so
one's about the flow so i'm looking at a
special class of deleterious mutations
these mla alleles that i'll talk about a
little later
how many of these per individual per
generation are coming in overall
mutation rates are thought to be
something like 70 per person per uh
generation now how many
ml most of them neutral how many m a
allele stock how many are we carrying
how many do you have inside you do i
have inside me on average
selection how big is the range of
selective costs that will fit into the
model and along with that antiquity what
is a typical age for these alleles
the most pressing
uh issue for demographers because it's
perfectly clear that humanity at least
is out of mutation selection balance now
that the onset of agriculture and
civilization have
enormously changed the selective
pressures on
any of these physiological pathways so
the antiquity of the alleles is the key
to their demographic relevance
now
i'd like to preface my talks by pointing
out that darwinian's natural selection
is a story about demographic success
it's about the
survival and offspring that one has that
organisms have across the life course
and these age-specific schedules as
david uh encouraged us to think
yesterday
are the proximate determinants of
fitness
that's the offspring
carry the genes onward to the next
generation
are born
at ages of their parents it's an age
structure and so
natural selection in the first place is
operating on and reshaping age-specific
demographic schedules
and the whole point of what makes this
interesting is that that age specificity
as david explained
means that uh
there's always epistasis anything that
is having age-specific effects on
fertility and survival is going to
affect alleles that are having
effects on other ranges
so
in honor of my phd dissertation
supervisor john kingman i wanted to
smuggle in a coalescent tree somewhere
and this is a coalescent tree for most
recent common intellectual ancestors
that is the mrcia
and so
on this right here
uh the leaves are topographers blowing
around across the parking lot and on the
left here you see the leaves a lot more
of them that are geneticists uh lots of
this room this side of the parking lot
and uh let's uh say i'm here and uh
so
a uh
coalescent tree
heading back to sir ronald fisher who
cared a lot about age-specific schedules
and indeed his uh repro specific
reproductive value function has become a
cornerstone of demographers stable
population theory
and fisher also did some genetics and so
he becomes a most an mrcia
for all of us
but uh this tree suffers from
incomplete linkage sorting because there
has been some lateral gene transfer very
recently
from sir peter meadower who developed
mutation accumulation and jbs haldane
who worked out relationships between
rates of new mutations and total loss in
fitness from deleterious alleles
so that's where we come together in this
subject we're going to have the legacy
of
fisher with lateral transfer from
haldane and meadowwar
epistasis david explained it in much
more detail
and
remind you we're looking at a framework
that became uh i think current uh from
kimura and kimura marayama but to which
we have added rapid recombination and so
we're looking at weakly selected
semi-dominant deleterious mutant alleles
random mating diploid inheritance but
the selective function is uh working on
haplotypes and so in that
setting there is the
classic expression uh in for
non-epistatic multiple alleles uh that
in every textbook where the net
reproduction ratio uh the measure of
fitness uh it's just the product of
these uh
individual costs and that can be
approximated for small s with an
exponential function
and
in our setting
we have a fitness specification that's
strongly analogous but
instead of just having the exponential
we have an integral outside the
exponential these are profiles that act
m
is indexing well i'll talk about what m
is indexing now we're summing over
alleles and integrating it against a
baseline and so
this piece is strongly analogous to what
you've all seen many times before but
it's the
averaging over a life course that
generates epistasis and i should mention
that the model is in continuous time i'm
trying to draw lessons about discrete
generation outcomes and this as my
colleagues will tell you is not without
challenges
okay really
comparing to like empirical
data is it obvious why you can ignore
dominance
oh
no
that's a complication that uh
that waits for later investigation
we've got enough problems before we go
there i don't think that's a difficult
problem but
well
basically i want to make i want to we're
going to do selection on haplotypes not
on uh
not on uh
deployed
he knows so
it's a story about genetic load and but
there are
four special features there's a lot of
literature coming out about genetic load
and its relevance
right now and we've benefited from a
paper by aquaball and whitlock a review
article that many of you have seen
but our piece fits into a special part
of that study of genetic load
david described our objects as mutations
but i've come more clearly to think of
them as teams of mutant alleles what is
being indexed here is a team of mutant
alleles drawn from widely separated
sites and what the members of a team
share is their age specific profile so
we have lots and lots and lots of sites
and then we pick out those scattered
sites
whose age specific effects are all
similar so we cluster
sites
by their age specific outcomes not their
physiological pathways they're operating
through very different physiology no
physiology in common perhaps but out
comes
age-specific outcomes
we cluster those together and then uh
for each team of
alleles we have some count
and we think of a lot of sites going
into the count
of uh one for one team
and now i'm restricting attention to a
subset of the load which i'll call m a
alleles for mutation accumulation and
these are the ones that are mildly
deleterious held in mutation selection
balance and affecting adult mortality
so
uh juvenile mortality and fertility are
another part of the model we're starting
with adult mortality which as david
pointed out uh
has great regularity among human
populations and similarities uh with a
number of model organisms so we're
looking at the part that is most similar
part of the mortality scheme part of the
demographic rate schedule it is most
similar across species that's our
starting point and the abandon this is
going to have some advantages that the
people thinking about genetic load don't
usually have
they have a problem with what on earth
could be a load-free genotype but for
adult mortality
we're not going to have that problem in
quite the same way
and that comes from the fact that uh the
highest survival uh probability for an
adult is a hundred percent you can't
have more than a hundred percent
survival so there's a bound on what the
load to free genotype can look like
and then the second advantage we have is
that for our epistatic setup with the
formulas that david gave you and i
recalled for you we have a closed form
expression for the adjustment that you
need to make in haldane's principle for
epistasis so in instead of talking about
the
modifications due to epistasis in a
general way we can actually calculate it
out it's a clean
closed theorem
and now also coming from demography
across the parking lot we just assume
that prehistoric population growth was
kept near zero so you have density
dependent feedback size dependent
feedbacks other kinds of feedback
systems that over the long course of
prehistory let
fertility and juvenile mortality adjust
to resources and predator threats and so
uh
the we're not looking at
loss of viability from the accumulation
of of
of mutations populations compensate for
that and keep the growth rate zero
there's enough potential of that
in respect it's resource base and and
the environment that governs the overall
growth rates
so there's sir peter meadower just to
have someone on the uh
have a picture somewhere in the slides
and uh this is the graph i mostly want
to talk about
so
remember we're going to have
an attempt to come up with
rough guesses at flows
rough guesses at stocks
use them to make rough guesses as where
in the range of selective costs are the
alleles i'm talking about and end up
trying to guess what the antiquity of
many of those alleles might be that's
our four
fold mission here and the first mission
is flows
what's the flow of alleles so there's
lots of
mutations mostly neutral
many entirely neutral coming in that are
measured
in contemporary ways especially from
actually linking families and
identifying new mutations 70 or so per
generation per person
but
i'm going to argue that my ma alleles
are a very tiny piece of this
and i think we have a way of getting at
the biggest share they could be per
individual per generation
on this
and uh here's the idea
anthropologists
bless their hearts and souls
before
existing surviving hunter-gatherer
tribes were
uh
changed by con by too much contact in
the early stages of contact did a lot of
measurement of life tables and
fertility schedules and so we have a
number of empirical life tables for
hunter gatherers
contemporary not prehistoric but they
give us some guide to hunter-gatherer
lifespans and here is the average
survival curve probability of surviving
that was estimated by michael girvin and
ellie kaplan from five fairly carefully
measured anthropological hunter-gatherer
schedules
i'm not talking about juvenile things
and this
schedule is essentially driven by a
gomparzian adult mortality curve that's
what they estimate
and uh
so
plus a background extrinsic mortality
so a constant level plus an exponential
and now
let us suppose that at least
some piece of that background
extrinsic mortality has nothing to do
with genetics
or let's say at least half of it doesn't
it's the tigers out there
mostly not tired but alligators in some
of these populations
and
if they happen on you they get you
well that then gives a kind of
maximal level that if you if for what
ever the genetics is doing to
reduce mortality at older ages the most
it can do is take you down from what
you'd have
anyway
could be a hundred percent that's not
from here too much but i'm going to let
it go down a little
to get to what you observe
so that's the most that these alleles
can be doing
and probably they're knowing less
because probably
the
outlook resource allocations and a
number of other pro adaptive processes
also imply as david mentioned also imply
that you're going to
have some
rise in senescent mortality rise in
mortality with age it's not just
genetics it's doing this so probably
what we think of a baseline without
these alleles should be somewhere in the
middle here but the most you can get is
that and that's going to play off
against a fertility schedule but when
you talk to anthropologists you don't
just want offspring you want nurture
anthropologists love to study parents
and grandparents the grand parenting
hypothesis and social species so i have
taken the demographer's
standard cold trestle natural fertility
schedule without contraception
and then i put in
some
smooth uh
allowances of a sort for the uh
good effects on your descendants of
having you their parents and their
grandparents survive
so
somewhat speculative but this is
in the range of shapes that everyone
thinks about oh and then what do we do
well we can compare
first of all we can compare the net
reproduction ratios if you have this
mortality curve
compared to what you can have with this
that gives you total fitness cost
and uh
then
and
in this example that comes out to be
about 0.13 about 13
loss
of
of that reproduction from these adult
mortality things if you push the worst
of the mortality that was observed in
these five populations you can push that
up to 0.3 or something but you can't
push it too much higher and then we have
a closed form formula which actually
looks a little like an entropy i won't
go into it but that's uh what
equates
the total rate of
team of mutations into teams of
mutations uh not now not to the total
loss in fitness but to a transformed
version of that and that gives you about
a factor of uh 50 percent more so
epistasis is giving you about 50 more
you need a higher mutation rate because
the more mutations you have the less
effect each one of them has and that
gets you in the range of one-fifth
one-fifth of one of my ma mutations
per time and if you push it you can get
it up to one-half
but i don't see any way to get it above
much above one half not one not two out
of those 70 things we're looking at us
per generation we're looking at a small
portion maybe one for one every five
generations coming in for this subclass
of mutational load
now that's important i think i hope the
people who work on genetic load listen
to us because they are worried about the
problem that so many mutations are
coming in that it doesn't seem that
mutation selection balance that we can
get rid of them we have to
knock off 80 percent of the possible
offspring all the time but for adult
mortality we don't have this problem one
every five
generations
is not such a wild thought for
a genetic cost on adult mortality that
something you're carrying is not quite
right one in five generations
will
uh kill you off in
an age range that matters for your
descendants it seems to me that's
that's
a number that doesn't cause worry
in a reasonable ballpark
now that was flows now we need stocks
so this sets me
trying to understand genetic literature
and uh
again
many thanks to uh
ian who's been helping me with this so
they're now whole genome or exome
sequencing studies and uh
so people are actually classifying
alleles single nucleotide variants uh
and uh work by tenessan and another by
nelson in this issue of science um this
is the one that i started drawing on and
it's the only one i know that
presented a published estimate of the
numbers that i wanted oh
so in background there it's only the
exome they have 2044 people split
between european and african descent
found
a pool of a half a million
single nucleotide variants that you
could find with this sample size uh on
average 14 000 per person mostly neutral
this is my other picture here oh this is
going to be a distribution by selective
cost times 10 to the minus four and a
lot of these are down by 10 to the minus
four
but
tenessen and company 20 companies 22 of
his friends
uh
gave numbers of between 300 and 600 for
average numbers of functionally
deleterious
uh
sniffs
which were carried by individuals on
different criteria for what one counts
as functional
so hundreds
not thousands not dozens
now these aren't quite the numbers we
want but they're closer than anything
else i've found
this is just the exo and we're talking
about processes that probably have a lot
to do with gene expression and
regulation so we'd expect there to be a
lot of
of uh
newton cases outside the exome but
maybe not huge factors
maybe there's a thousand of these total
something like that rather than 300 but
then we're restricting to m a allele so
that brings us back down again and we
don't know how much but perhaps
a third a fifth
maybe more maybe less but not
perhaps a tenth or a hundredth uh i
think we're better than within an order
of magnitude uh
for the astronomers among you i would
say we're in an e-folding a factor of e
for these numbers perhaps
and so if you put these together we have
0.20 coming in and we have something
like 300 hanging around
so a selective cost is coming out to be
something like uh
10 some
multiple of 10 to the minus three
well
a multiple of ten to the minus three
is what
makes demographic sense
but
i didn't
when i did these calculations i didn't
understand that that's
what i wanted it to come out at i
promise you it came out and then they
didn't explain to me that that is what
makes sense so in these neutral we're
so
we think of for european populations or
we think of uh effective population
sizes of 10 000 so we're in 10 to the
fourth at 10 to the fourth drift is
taking over so when you're down here
things at the 10 to the minus 4 level
that's
effectively neutral
over here
up here when you get to 10 to the minus
2 level those are going out
that in
historical numbers of generations that's
strongly selected things that's things
you can see in g watts studies that's
over here and
our
pieces are coming in 10 to the minus
3ish in the middle of the board where we
want them to be where i'm talking to you
guys
so
i found great encouragement from that
notion that we seem now to be talking
about a
regime where what matches what one's
seen in the
sequencing studies is uh
compatible with
what the demographic story really needs
we're 10 to the minus 4 a model that
has no drift
would be useless if it were that's over
here if it were 10 to the minus 2 we'd
be talking about very detailed
physiology instead we're talking about a
statistical accumulation of small things
and so
in the general way the antiquity of
alleles is
under selection and right fischer models
with selection is
somewhat proportional to the inverse of
the selective cost and we um have an
actual in our equations that comes out
to be true average uh
selective cost and so uh in the time
scale then
1500 generations
some of them there's a huge variation
around them but a lot of this is an
ancient legacy operating when mortality
was severe enough to be like
hunter-gatherer levels so that
you lost people during reproduction and
so these proportions were putatively
shaped in these high mortality regimes
before all the changes that you see
from civilization
why are you ignoring the change in
population sign i'm not you have set me
up for it
uh so now comes the point
this goes on up to here and what
the writers tenessen in particular say
is
explosive population growth this is a
fraction of 0.001
uh my one per thousand population growth
is explosive in this world
and not not in the world that
contemporary demographers work with
so
when they found this they hypothesized a
very large number of these snips
are the result of this signature of
explosive growth and then there's been a
series of papers looking at this the one
one of the ones that i've studied uh
most is the price of a and then
anti-clark and people uh but there's
another by a a person named simons yuval
simons these may all be people known to
you but they're new to me and what they
mostly find is that the large increase
in
numbers of
single nucleotide variants happens
largely down here
in the nearly neutral range so there's a
huge increase can be attributed as a
simulation work on models
can be attributed to changes recent
changes being last 400 generation
changes in population size and that the
numbers here in the middle of mildly
deleterious alleles are much
less strongly effective so that's what i
read the literature this is still coming
out that's what i read the literature to
say that the recent population growth is
affecting mainly
the ones down here
not a closed issue but that's that's
what i read the new studies to say
so coming back and summarizing uh what
uh
what looks to me to be the case or how
many uh per individual something like
one per five generations how many of
these particular adult mortality
affecting alleles
something in the hundreds uh
selective costs well into the mildly
deleterious range that you won't see in
gwas but which will contribute to
heritability and uh will
presumably not be tied to very special
big things that use that depend on
today's environment
like the presence of chocolate bars or
something or things that have big
effects today
are not in this picture and enough of
them well back in prehistory
that you have a historical story
so
can you say something about how you're
calculating the antiquity
how i'm counting the calculating of
these mutations
well
i'm not going to say a lot this is
early
modeling but the basic picture uh is one
over the average selective cost is going
to be an average
age for these mildly selected pieces but
you need to take into account the
population growth
well
if godzave and clark and simons and
others were finding that the last 400
generations mattered i would need to do
this
if
it doesn't matter much to this regime
which
is not my claim it's just my reading of
the literature then the reconstruction
of these populations
then there's a long paper by clark and
his team
reconstruct the european based
population at pretty close to with a
bottleneck and then pretty close to an
effective population size of 10 000 for
most of that
time period so if i get
back behind 400 generations i'm
understanding that i can pretty much uh
let enso be
be uh
not not over here
not for the nearly neutral but up here
for
those things that are
well better than drift that i can i can
as a first cut just take one over grass
now
monte slatkin has been here and and
others
i'm aware there's a literature on
estimating allele ages and there will be
from the site frequency spectra of these
ones should be able to do much better
but in first
approximation that's what i'm taking
it's tough i mean they're not so far
apart right uh 400
generations and a thousand generations
okay i mean the
i welcome discussion of this i'm just
saying where the point at which i've
arrived oh
for demographers i should say
these
growth rates less than one per thousand
half per thousand quarter per thousand
are pretty
small
but
it's clearly a question how much do they
one could do so i've done some
simulations myself and they do fancy
simulations and see how much difference
it does make
oh so i'm just ending up with a piece uh
the frontis piece from the book that um
incorporated demographers into this site
where all the
book called
collection called between zeus and the
salmon zeus the exemplar of a creature
who lives forever and the salmon the
exemplar of a creature who spawns and
dies and for demographers the goal has
been to
find our place between zeus and the
salmon
i'm encouraged that genome sequencing
studies tied in with the mathematical
models that in fischer's tradition
recognize the importance of age seemed
to me to be giving us a reasonably
consistent picture of the genetic
uh
in likely
scope of genetic influences on adult
mortality
so i take questions or arguments i take
it
i am taking it that i am hearing some
skepticism on these
simulation claims that worrying about
the last few hundred generations
is not something i have to worry about
is it am i getting the right
your messages are not
so much bigger
uh than than one over the time this this
time scale population growth
yeah i guess it seems like the prior and
when mutations arise
is strongly influenced by population
size
so the very large population size
recently seems to be putting a lot of
mutations in
but into them and a lot of people
so these are remember rates per person
yeah what tennessean and company we're
most concerned with is the whole
ensemble you get hundreds of thousands
and most of them become recent but
you've also got a lot more people
to divide them by
oh
well there are a couple things i mean
first on the thing of exponentially
growing population size you tend to have
long tips on the
you know
genealogies which will allow for more
accumulation of mutations
and a different thing i worry about is
sort of population structure
you know things like oscar nazi jews
you know and certain populations with
small effective
you know
population sizes that
harbor
galilee's mutations
in this world i am a consumer
i know that these are problems that i'm
not don't have the expertise to solve
and
i am eager that
the population genetics world
tells me
what to be putting in
i agree and when i lie in bed and think
about these things population structure
worries me a lot because for demographer
effective population size is a very
strange thing and happily
we're talking about spatial
spatial structuring and the
breeding pools are small things and then
you ask well do they really spread out
all across europe in
50 generations
there's a a study by rhodey chang and
also which claimed that the most recent
common ancestor of all of us lived at
about the time julius caesar was
murdered
he actually tracked flows across alaska
and so forth
so that gives his dna to everybody in
the planet
no
because the dna goes up linearly this is
genealogical ancestry
i'm basically agreeing with you
okay
no this is genealogical ancestor
yeah yeah yeah yes okay yeah this is a
two to the n and
genetic ancestry goes up like n or two n
yeah and so no that that's it's not at
all
but
in terms of the anthropology
of whether small flows over hundreds of
generations
mix people up
some part of me thinks
very at random mating very odd here and
some part of me thinks well hundreds of
generations very long time
and i don't know where to go
between it but yes
i know i won't solve this but it is
something i worry about
at night
um yeah so i think the things that i
would be concerned about most would be
episodes
dominance um
effects i don't maybe those don't matter
in some way but
for people who don't think so and just
also i wasn't clear like if you
put in well remember these things are
pretty rare although they're not i've
just discovered they're not as rare as i
thought i thought they were going to be
quite rare and in fact the dominance or
mutation
if they're rare enough you don't get
homozygotes
so
but they're
they're not as rare as i
was expecting them to be and when i
started understanding what was site
frequency spectra so the issue you're
raising
comes back at me
if these things were very rare then i
wouldn't
worry about it but keep going
just
wait so is it
how did you get like the peak of
it coming at ten to the minus three uh
the the kind of main effect of alleles
of size two minus three
well i just looked at what people were
simulating in the genetic literature
so
there was some calculation
so
what's the
world of
understanding is most new mutation a lot
of these single snvs are totally neutral
a lot of them are
roughly neutral people plug in gammon
distributions
and the cutoffs when you've got an
effective population size of 10 uh of 10
to before then oh
somehow what neutral
is 10 to the 4ish and what strongly
selected means is 10 to the 2ish i'm not
yeah but he i think he asked me that the
calculation you had for why the n a
alleles yeah why the the important
regime for the maa wheels
i'm getting this out of my gusset flow
divided by my guess at stock okay okay
to kind of balance the
plugs and stuff
well and and i have a closed form
adjustment for episodes that's what
makes this
that's what makes that's what we have
to offer
to a wider community there's actually a
closed form
adjustment to aldine's principle
so it's not just we've got this fitness
and then there's some
fudge factor or other we've got this
fitness and then we can calculate the
fudge factor so that's where i came up
with the 1500s wait wait but then you
calculate kind of
influx of mutations times fixation
probability with this kind of curve it
comes out consistent
none of these are
none of these are going are
these once they once they fix
they're called probability
and remember once they fix
the feedback adjusts for them anyway so
the fixes are
are gone in this picture okay
graham has another con
so
it's now known
that the
merely important mutation is
that doesn't get incorporated at all but
as you say that's the big recent study
and i know greg cochrane and henry
harpending and others a lot of people
are now trying to see how that matters
and again i'm on the consuming end of
that research i want to find out how it
matters but
they
that study
where they're seeing it oh that's up in
the seventh day i'm they're talking
about
a pattern of mutation rates with
paternal age
in an ensemble of 70 things per person
in these families that were with uh with
what is it a schizophrenia or something
some bad some bad condition they're
looking at where they've got pedigrees
and so that's out of 70.
whether that's so important for my
0.2 out of 70
i don't know i'm waiting to see but
there's some interesting stories i
understand being put together
predicated on that and of course because
of the different ages of male for
different ranges of male fertility it
might well come into that calculation
i'm doing but i'm waiting
for more literature i can drawn
this this this sprint for concavity yes
so is that an assumption here and can
you remind us what that means
well
here it just follows from so there's a
general model which can have any cost
function in it which th which
mathematics works for then we put in the
demographic cost functions that i've
been showing in which there are
age-specific profiles for effects of
alleles the concavity is automatic in
that case
because what it's saying
die once
you can't die again that's the concavity
so can you have combinations of alleles
that are antistatic and that they're
only bad if they're there together oh
yep so none of that is in here so this
is one piece of epistasis i'm trying to
spotlight on one piece there are all
kinds of other pieces
which have been talked about here where
you can have critical points in some
chain network that are knocked out and
so none of that's in here
well it would certainly
change outcomes the question is whether
how dominant
is that for
these kinds of things that operate over
very long
time periods
knocking out something in the jade
network as we heard kind of a big effect
that's what give the fat tails and that
pushes us out where these things
have to be understood in recent
environments
mutations in a regulatory region
help you code all that none of that's in
here
all that would might what might affect
the more refined picture that we'd like
to have in the future
okay well thank you very much